livello belli la madonna che a livello
bellissimo bello vero
allora se è bello vero lo facciamo senza
neanche line trovò così lo facciamo
subito il livello più bello che io abbia
mai fatto in tutta la mia vita non c'è
fottutamente storico da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono vaghi j
oggi siamo su come si chiama questo
gioco si chiama happy wings ma vanno
avrei mai detto ormai è una fissa mortal
kombat shanxi oh mio dio no ma sei serio
ma io volevo prendere la spada invece ho
guadagnato uno stomaco e non è la stessa
cosa ma devo prendere la spada cosa che
no gli ho lanciato la mia gamba spero
sia letale di ho preso la testa
lucci o la madonna cos'è ragazzi la
mossa del killer
io prendo e stacco le teste una cosa che
faccio di solito devo capire un attimo
come sosta roba che ce la posso fare non
mi toccare il pene non mi toccare se
dici che me l'ha toccato il pene non è
bello lungo ragazzi è impossibile
minchia mezz'ora per falsa che è ma
allora sei stronzo però va dai un'ora e
mezza che pro vasto alta sta stronzata
che è successo io staccato umbra ok
amico mio ti andrebbe di togliere il tuo
pugno dal mio culo 6 vogliano i ragazzi
una roba alquanto invece o mio dio come
ho fatto
ragazzi ci sto facendo ci si può credere
o dio mio santo you allora senti è di
non fare finta di essere un ninja perché
non lo sei è una roba tipo neanche
scorpion ti fa una pippa ha proprio così
mica è il ninja più atletico è snodabile
che abbia mai visto in tutta la mia vita
ragazzo io non so come fa a essere così
con questi movimenti molto fluidi bravo
ed i bravissimi complimenti sub zero
affanculo ho fatto gol charles ricordavo
pochi giovane crediti pro va bene lo
stesso sei sempre bello zio no need non
me ne frega niente basta che vinco
perfetto è stata la cosa più bella di
sempre altro che bello vero questo è
proprio bello gnocco tra uccelli centro
challenge vi ispira ci fa luke ti sei
messo a vendere la frutta e il tuo
lavoro è di melo prima no che cazzo che
è corso troppo figo che io posso
spararle madonna manco robin hood è
stato beccato pure la zucca mia mi stava
sul culo la zucca si vede baseball swing
mi che avesse bellissimo
ma seriamente tap space touring è la
madonna che fuori campo era mica è
esplosa letteralmente a tribuna guardalo
lì sì ma steve po più di reazioni mio
dio riprovare nati ogni nuovo non so
cosa ho sbagliato ma ok bella
ok è andata bene solo la prima volta
adesso faccio cagliari
bravo post streetbike o mio dio è una
roba da mandare con le bici bike penso
fosse bici col cazzo è la moto di
valentino ed è come ragazzina by prendi
apprendi apprendi la prendi la gioca
così make up i will makoveev a dovendo
la virtus a ecco c'era una volta me che
è più mia pitturato la moto ma come
madonna rega e bellissimo suo livello
non ho mai fatta una roba così [ __ ]
ho finito pure in back flip e la madonna
ragazzi non mai più una roba così chi
cazzo sei tu partita a testa a qualcuno
ma ok da sat la stessa moda tra sandra
sì c'è interni studi no c'è mensa vanne
ho capito savant il mugens trish hadden
remake okapi tante remake gesù marce
sarebbe jumanji piume e le scienze
svendsen e can b espace 15 a uno spasmo
offende strette completo english scritto
che puzzo che mi devo lavorare vabbè
playnow fatemi vedere cos'è sto savane
incredibile che mi sembra a e salame e
che caschi sono sarà negazione di
scrivere a [ __ ] ci sono i turisti
tra l'altro belletti giorno volete
vedere un animale bellissima è brutto e
[ __ ] si chiama uk mi piaceva ve
lo regalo e beve gratis come souvenir
guarda la testa e lì se volete prenderlo
prendete una giraffa come elefanti che a
livello è questo fatemi capire io devo
sopravvivere nella savana
rip del crocodile mano ha ucciso il
coccodrillo è stato il sellino ragazzi
il sellino e malvagio
va bè ragazzi lasciamo al sellino che
un'arma da fuoco non indifferente
nightfall sindone fa scendendo la notte
la madonna ma ancora leone non così
figli fatti capire dove devo andare
niente ma come mai finito così ci sono i
gabbiani ragazzina definizione
leggermente alta hd superman selling
cosa sta roba mio dio devo lasciarmi
andare volare al posto di serio
mica è più superman uk ma fatemi provare
un attimo e della sinistra settario
nicchia che centro come ho fatto se ci
riprova non ci riuscirò mai più nella
vita tipo però ha in compenso ucciso un
folletto vabbè dai basta l'ultima giusto
per cosa appena successo cosa
per la patata che cazzo amico mio ti va
una 69 cambia non va bene
un'altra volta juran cos'è sta cosa mio
dio ogni volta che leggo ranno paura
ragazzone i tasti che saltano ma cos'è
sentiro ecco bravo vai tu perché mica
non è positiva e vai vai vai vai mai
cominciò la gamba mio dio ho vinto non
va beh come ho fatto a pedalare così per
tutto sto tempo est mort ancora con
mortai como ma perché tutti su mortal
kombat ii scopriva ve ne è uscito però
cazzo a stronzo de merda dimettesse da
usare la mia gamba come piedistallo ma
ti rendi conto sergej opa certo che fare
un livello da sergej mi sembra molto
molto strano prova da sergej o e massei
stronza lo ha sentito io allora già che
non mi hai tolto le gambe almeno fai tu
da gambe fugge non ti aggrappare a mio
pene come mai questa gamba e attaccata
cosa stesso che sono diventato un
necromorfo cosa ma do perché c'è una
gamba che mi sfrutta dal collo ragazzi è
un horror questo non è più happy meal
kids era auto ragazzi ma perché
continuano a fare questi livelli devo
uscire la madonna che casino veramente
come cazzo faccio sia da tutta sta roba
impossibile ok ok a parte che c'è una
gamba già fuori come sia possibile
ancora non lo so la gamba ha vinto va
già bene così ragazzi già un traguardo
questo mi spiegate il senso visto
livello ragazzi di quadri colipa vai
veloce che fenomeno aggrappati a
qualcosa attaccati al cazzo piuttosto ma
attaccati propria o che gioia madonna
manco avessi vinto i mondiali survive a
me lo stai chiedendo zio me lo stai
afferma chuene tu non sai cazzo fanno
loro la sedia prendi la sedia fatti
scudo
no non ho fermi sempre qualcosa per
coprirmi come cazzo mi fa
sono vivo non fate domande sei più belli
ma come save ville a parte quelle luke
primo è ma io vi devo prendere un
machete nel collo a posto di uk ma
[ __ ] bambini con la mannaia nel
culo cioè normale e bambine con spade
nel collo ma ovvio la guest botton run
ma sei serio zio pensi di poter fare un
bottone anche io non riesco a fare non
ha idea di chi sia cazzo sta facendo o
mio dio ragazzi la ruota di yafran data
voi non le vedete ma le gambe io ce l'ho
ancora da qualche parte i fas or die si
veloce o muori cosa succeda no ho
cliccato cose a caso perché avevo paura
di non riuscirci ok è tanto ce lo sto
anche facendo convinto proprio di essere
forte ma invece sono un [ __ ] dai
cazzo si no ma come ma dai mappa
[ __ ] a dio mio forza bravo posso
fare dai dai dai dai ucciso non un ciak
non so come se è perfetto una persona
soddisfatta street fighter mio dio e
così capisci che è una giornata di merda
quando c'è liuc con una mannaia così
perché ascoltami zio ci hai un tuo
simile qui vai a rompere ecco allora non
per cortesia o sei tullio che da vecchio
è proceduto a mi segue sa che seguì non
rido strappati investono la ruota di
dietro ecco perfetta adesso sono morto
come ho fatto a morire io te tutta gente
con le spade ma perché poi le carte man
amico mio sei esattamente l'uomo karate
credimi bravo bravo lui arditamente
grosso ma riesco ha superato cazzo ho
fatto un acrobazia per superarlo già sul
boss e mi ha ucciso il boss non mi ha
uccisi mi ha ucciso
porca [ __ ] perché sono morto ormai
fissato niente di omino sono solo
machete nel culo 1 nel collo uno nella
schiena ma cosa vuoi che sia
cos'è oh mio dio ma dove vai
come di sonate in gra farmi steve più
sesso c'è un certo punto non stavo
capendo più niente ma ok guarda come
pedalò guarda come pedalò holy shit
parlano guardano tutte l'impennata
guardalo incredibile tutto lui a caso
quello sì in groppa la spada vai così ma
è così spinge il nigger cosa sta
succedendo allora devo superare babbo
natale che si sta inquinando a me
giustamente è il suo folletto che se lo
sta inglobando prima di arrivare al
traguardo io ce la farò adottate non ci
sono riuscito 9,1 sono ancora mio pane
ragazzi riesco a farlo senza guardano
guardo neanche come a livello anno nella
partito perfetto d'accordo ragazzi si è
bloccato qui caso ha deciso di morire è
non so se è lui che fa questo effetto
probabilmente mi fai ripartire e privi
sprofondi in sé fresatori nostro blu
cervi ricordatevi che lui è l'artefice
di che cos'è
cosa ho cliccato è partito ma no non
volevo far partire dai sono un fenomeno
questi giochi in crisi i ragazzi altro
che happy with c'è questo che un gioco
con dinosauro che sono anche morto
perché faccia che fa con d'umore
realistico di ragazzine che possono
chiudere qui spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto è stato un po strano oggi
perché pensava lenta la connessione ogni
tanto slap non so come mai quindi
ragazzi se siete più belli di saw tizio
e se vi è piaciuto il video documento vi
piace anche a pacciani facebook e come
ogni video tratta nelle scrizione serse
vorresti discretissimi europeo vinto
belle ragazze